[Music]
in too many doughnuts news no such
[ __ ] thing you know who's been
really killing it these days is um
Dunkin Dunkin donut good like a person I
think they came up with a new formula or
whatever like their doughnuts to me used
to be like wind chills and all the
regular donut mom and pop ones
yeah but then no that's the coffee that
we use at home Oh vanilla oh about their
Donuts it's done changed on me it's as
good as Krispy Kremes oh hell no no the
Krispy Kreme Doughnuts those are from
God yeah that's some God in like 30
minutes it's soft in Greece a gateway
drug race me up but Dunkin Donuts has
like a it's like a lightness to it where
it's like the opposite of a Krispy Kreme
whipping cream is lighter than Krispy
Kreme its opposite in the way that
Krispy Kreme is more greasy or like it's
more oily and then yeah and in Duncan's
more like it's like almost baked like
it's different it's fluffy it's
different I don't know I don't want all
that one deep-fried doughnut also you'll
know how Krispy Kreme great mark means
well they had that sign that will light
up when the donuts were hot my mom and I
will be driving home she mean she'd be
leaving her somewhere and we see that
sign lit up yeah we with hot coffee is
really good yeah God emotional because
it's really sweet without it I got to do
a video oh this video apparently this is
not about Krispy Kreme I'm sorry I
forgot y'all this is submitted by ants
in my pants make me do that bougie dance
beast cops are being sent to a special
belly adjusting camp you know what's
good thank you
that's a good thing right I want cops to
catch me [ __ ] that [ __ ] keep them fat
are you insane
like I want them to be sick and deadly
oh you don't want cops catch Roger
that's crazy they don't have weight and
height regulations because even in the
military there was a an height
regulation yes where's that your BMI
like tall you are you can only weigh a
certain amount
oh and like a weight regulation and then
hi it like you have to be certain height
- it's like a BMI height and weight
regulation in military and if you were
if your BMI was too high you wouldn't be
able to get promoted I mean you have to
be a certain way cuz you gotta you got
to be able to fit in a plane fit in the
tank crawl them whatever it's not but
it's it's a starting point and then so
there's people that are bodybuilders of
course so their BMI is way off cuz like
there's circumference so [ __ ] huge
and their weight is big but their waist
is really small so if they could still
complete the physical fitness test at a
very high level than they get excuse I
wonder why I thought like cops not the
same I wonder why they don't they've
never had that
well they do when you first start
there's like a fitness test there's well
once you get in that's it yeah depending
on a department I heard I don't think
that's right though cuz you know drivers
you have to retake the driving test like
why can't cops retake a physical they
probably do but it's probably easy as
[ __ ] I feel like they would have
something that says like you know I go
wait regulate I mean like tender they
got height and weight regulations you
know the girls got height regulations
the men got tender what it is yeah
tender the app hating it mm-hmm you
can't get on that app for more than 20
minutes without somebody asking how tall
are you height would have mattered to a
guy would it to a guy sorry Thomas is
proportionate yeah I mean most people
are tender like I mean I don't use
anymore but most people on tender they
literally put their like stats cuz I'm
not looking at a finance girl right and
I'm let's say eyeballs on tinder right
and this girl's [ __ ] finest [ __ ] yeah
I see her she's five foot one unlock a
minute no the problem is guys that are
five foot seven and match because a lot
of girls I have trouble dating are like
five like nine or like 5 10 sometimes
and they don't like they're like oh I
don't know like I know a girl has a
height regulation for a boy but I don't
know if boys had that for a girl cuz if
I there's some guys yeah I'm sure there
are
oh really yeah cuz they want to feel
like like dominant imagine me like a lot
of guys might be like damn cheat at all
like I actually feel more dominant if
they're taller than me you feel more
dominant yeah because I'm like
I got this monster monster cuz I feel
six-foot-five so I don't give a [ __ ]
Oh everybody look little to me you do
have a big personality so I think
confidence goes a long way because you
know I mean there's like Tim Tam our
friend Tim he's not a big dude he seems
tallest [ __ ] he does yeah he feels like
big and spirit which you kind of forget
how tall he is how short he is yeah
at work I always I wear these four and a
half inch heels all the time and they're
very loud and like chunky cuz I want
people to know when I'm coming but I
think I'll wear them when I went to do
the podcast at your house and like one
day I came to work and I was wearing
loafers and somebody was like cuz I
literally shrink by like five inches but
I don't notice like I literally don't
notice like I feel like I'm seven feet
tall so that this just you notice but I
think having height though like half of
the work is done as far as the presence
they keep you're already a tall person
you could be shy it could be whatever
but your presence is big because
physically you know surprised you'd be
surprised because then there's also
those people that sound like this just
so that they can blend it they could be
looking at you you know those people
you're definitely true I guess I haven't
seen too many shorter guys with the tall
girl I mean you guys are you're not that
far off though so I don't really count
you guys are really close but like okay
Bart makes up for it on and with so this
like as if it was a it was a skinnier
guy the same size of Bart it it would
look you would stand out way more oh
yeah
my name's Bart got it yeah cuz I'm the
same height as Bart with the skinnier
yeah but I haven't seen a five-foot sick
dude with the Hoover like a six-foot
girl before I did it a five-point sick
dude before really yeah I it was yeah -
there's a lot of it there's some guys
that are like super into that but it's
more of like a fetish kind of thing you
know like like giant women like I
stumbled on this weird subreddit and it
was like I want a woman to crush me with
her body
I've seen those infernal where there's a
super small guy and this big tall woman
like Amazonian woman is like cradling
him yeah she bucks him I saw this one
one time where they were like in front
of a staircase and this dude he was like
what was it and she was like a like a
tall Japanese woman oh no I didn't know
yeah yeah it was like a like in for
something it was like the stairs were
there for scale because he was normal
size and she hadn't been at least like
six nine or something and then she had
like those like bangs they were like
this and she was looking at him like I'm
going to [ __ ] you and like he was so
down for it you know that's that
Freudian [ __ ] who's that girl screaming
and there's the guy
I was getting murdered there's
definitely two standards forgotten guys
would be like oh the [ __ ] standard
and the the relationship standard right
so when guys are looking they might be
like oh I might want to touch your
titties because they're massive but then
they don't want to date them yes you
know like funny so yeah guys have that
like like curiosity for physical you
know some girls have that you yep like I
wonder how big his dick is well I'm
shagging him that girl the one that he
dated was that she was like the height
different something I was so real life
doesn't wife we got married his wife
that he had with his kids is like half
his size she's like what that was the
girlfriend no no yeah the one that was
on those checks but aren't normal women
like that size next to shot true yeah
unless he dates of like she was really
small the way I'm talking about Oh like
Yao Ming and his wife you know like her
both tallest [ __ ] do shoutouts to Yao
Ming and his English being [ __ ] good
dude it's really good now yeah it's
really good like you oh yeah this takes
place in Thailand there are about 200
policemen that are to participate in a
two-week program called a belly
destruction program do they eat a lot of
donuts [ __ ] up there is the is the cops
is the cops donut lovers out there too
they've been too much I wouldn't be
surprised every time I think of a 3000
feet every time I think of a third-world
cop
I do think like are they all bald fat as
hell yeah they look happy though yeah
and then they just cooter Wow that's
that was me in Hawaii last year that's
she thing is that's not overweight in
America in America that's not overweight
though that's most cops yeah that's
crazy Thailand are considered obese I
can't believe that they're not being
attacked like that like in a two week
program some have soup and [ __ ] pad
thai dude they've gone down about what
is it maybe like 40 pounds oh [ __ ]
that's a lot yeah I bet you they don't
even give them food kilos down to 60 so
what is that that's 20 like 20 kilos
that's 44 pounds that's a lot of weight
one shrimp everyday one shrimp
Sawatdee shrimp damn forty pounds and
hollow to weak vegetable oh it's
possible is very unhealthy two weeks
forty forty I don't think so forty-four
pounds unless they're [ __ ] all
hydrated well that's why I'm saying like
in Biggest Loser they do that [ __ ] which
is terrible forty-four pounds that
sounds they were those sixty pounds in a
week saying that police stations
nationwide will nominate two to three of
their fattest cops to participate in
this program at a time this is for
entertainment what if I was a cop and
they came up to me during the time I was
fat and they go David we're gonna
nominate you I'm like but I'm not fat so
what do you mean like no you're fat no
that's point where somebody else you're
like dude this right here this is all
muscle what are you talking about who's
who
there's cops in the states that are like
five times some of those guys oh yeah
they look like they need a [ __ ]
electric wheelchair to catch people and
[ __ ] they look like they don't [ __ ]
take ten hours to get out of the cop car
there's some bad [ __ ] American cops
yeah like I always in the movies like
their TV show stereotypically the guy
that's like not on the field is the big
guy so it just makes me think that like
after their first day of not being on
the field they're like Brenda fire up
the stove
I think cops should be on a regular
regimen of steroids angry no but like
the regulated one not know where they
could agree that's a good
idea because this is essentially a super
drug right to get you strong and fit and
healed but not like the way that people
do it how about the Russian Olympic wave
where they just regulated because you
know a lot of cops these days don't even
chase after the criminal like in on foot
pursuit anymore you don't slide on the
hood of the car anymore
they just create a perimeter they call
the bird and they just have their backup
come and they use technology to catch
them there are a lot of cars on steroids
I follow a bunch of cop IG guys and
they're a lot more like crazy jacked
[Music]
[Music]